des en-cas y ait cette marie c'est la
volonté de saint-yves rangon pour les
municipales dentiste père de quatre
enfants il se présente comme une
alternative au maire sortant sans
étiquette il ne devait être affilié à
aucun parti son objectif redonner à la
ville ses lettres de noblesse je ne vais
pas avec cette paris ne bouge pas il ya
un immobilisme
il n'y a rien qui se passe les projets
qui étaient bien avant n'ont jamais été
réalisé les actions ne sont pas faites
c'est paris m sont des compétences à
mener à bien les dossiers donc sept
maris et à kayes et en 2017 lors des
municipales partielles de cette marie
saint-yves rangon n'avait pas pu se
présenter à cause de problèmes
administratifs
deux ans plus tard il vient avec la
volonté de créer un choc de changer les
choses est de libérer la parole les gens
à sept maris ont une grain un grand
problème de crète
ils ne peuvent pas s'exprimer parce que
le pouvoir en place agissent uniquement
sur ça je le redis c'est pousse à mon
slogan c'est s'il vous plaît pas peur à
soupapes et nous ne pouvons pas vivre
sous le joug de dictateurs c'est pas
possible
satire rangon vient donc grossir le
nombre de candidats sept maris une
élection municipale qui s'annonce
passionnante